dites moi où et scott clark c'est pas si
simple que ça quand scott simmons est
connu il était pas aux appareils
et je ne parle pas que de sa cellule du
lot dès sa femme venait demander le
divorce et là je lui fais genre au maire
ta femme te placard temps au temps mon
pote et l'une fait ouais je croyais y
aller moi c'était forêt d'othe et
maintenant je me retrouve tout seul je
vais te laisse pas abattre mon pote
parce que je suis sûr que tu retrouveras
nos matches mais tu sais quoi je
m'appelle louise lui fait que tu sais
quoi je m'appelle scottish rétablir
qu'en mode accord aux sports j'adore les
bonnes histoires comme tout le monde
mais c'est quoi le rapport avec
l'endroit où se trouve scott ce mondial
nous avait mis une pièce dans la machine
va falloir vous farcir la chanson
jusqu'au bout ce gars-là c'est comme un
jukebox
[Musique]
c'était un plaisir de négocier avec vos
amis
changement de programme accroche toi
[Musique]
récupérez le laboratoire que n'importe
comment
non
on voit qu'ils ont pas pris l'option
châssis exemplaires